I'm Billy Eilish and I'm going to be
playing her puppies while I'm answering
fans question okay here's was annoying I
hate the color blue
especially favorite color I don't know
how I ended up dying in blue and then I
remember like I just lived with it for a
while and then I was like I realized
that I was somebody with colored hair
that didn't I didn't clock that I had
blue hair but I didn't think I was
someone with blue hair I just thought I
had blue hair and I was me and then I
realized like when people walk by me
they probably were like oh she has blue
hair you know as you do when you see
somebody with colored hair I wanted to
change it to like dark grey I was told
that whoever dyed my hair in October
used like a permanent blue so that is
not coming out I have sat in that stupid
salon chair for hours and hours and
hours and hours and hours and hours and
hours and hours and hours and hours and
hours and hours and hours and hours
trying to get the blue out now
[Music]
you know what lyrics are kind of I think
the hardest part for me like I am better
at melodies and chords but I'd say
lyrics are probably like the thing that
takes the longest probably so it really
depends I mean I write songs starting
with all kinds of things it could start
with lyrics I could start with melody
chords be whatever you want I can't even
think
six years ago I want to say or something
I was in my house home alone I was gonna
do grilled cheese I was almost done I
was like you know getting everything
ready I was like one it's an avocado so
I opened the fridge and I was like where
the avocados and in my head I was like
ha that'd be funny if I made out my
username and then I didn't even do it
and then like a couple days later I was
like what was that thing I said where
are the avocados and be funny as hell so
I made up my username I don't know I'm
hella nervous for Coachella
dude I'm I've been having nightmares
about it it's gonna be crazy it's gonna
be super like disorienting and getting
scary I don't know I hope it hope it's
just fun I don't want it to be like
boring I don't want people just standing
there I want people moving who am I so
excited to see it I'm happy to see
Ariana dude she's so cool bro she's so
cute she's so talented she's like one of
the most talented people I feel like in
the world like I'm not even gonna say
female cuz one of those talented females
not that just such as the talented
cooking God who else is playing
Coachella me I'm excited to see me
downtime is funny um I don't have
downtime
I actually really like baking so I like
baking cookies a lot any sort of time to
do anything I just baked chocolate chip
peanut butter chocolate chip cookies or
the other day I baked the Buckeyes just
like this peanut buttery thing inside
this like chocolate ball oh my god it's
hot I don't know I was like the worst
that was like my worst phase I was just
really annoying
I feel like 13 is the worst age 13 is
just like everything you do is annoying
as hell and everyone you know is
horrible I'm trying to think there have
been a lot of moments that are that I'll
never forget I'm probably music Midtown
in Atlanta it was like 40,000 people
standing there screaming all my lyrics
that I wrote in my bedroom years ago
everyone at the festival was at my show
singing my lyrics it was it was
unbelievable okay well
[Music]
my first song I wrote what I wrote my
first song I wrote my first song at like
a lemon and I wrote it about the walking
dish didn't Zeus fire
well actually I wrote my first fire when
I was like 4 probably on the ukulele and
it was like oh called what a wonderful
life because we lay all day and I comfy
bed what a wonderful life we play
outside in the green grass what a
wonderful life we smell all the roses in
that rose bush what a wonderful life um
yeah that's probably the first one oh
yeah I'm like gentleman I'm trying to do
that now I've always loved fashion I've
always loved the idea of doing that and
like since day one I've just like I've
been the one that designs on my merch
obviously I have to do now so I don't
have enough time to like do that but
it's everything I ever made it so
curated by me it's all like my ideas and
my thoughts my everything am i right see
here's that's a good question because
favorite music video to shoot none of
them are very fun to shoot because I've
been doing some dumb it to get a good
video I think putting spiders in my
mouth and putting black ink in my eyes
going upside down in the middle of a
dirty ass stinky ass hotel there's no
like doodoo this baby boy right now
Avril Lavigne drops harder than skater
would fire that other one fire I'm with
you as far as he Batmobile goes hard huh
oh I did I love the album I'm so glad I
love the album I just I'm so happy I do
cuz it's so common to not love the music
that you make so I'm really happy I do
but I feel like I have favourites for
different moods I don't even know I feel
like my favorite one I've written is
probably I love you my favorite one my
favorite ones are just listened to I
love very friend I love Iloilo I love
bad guys [ __ ] is so [ __ ] good they're
all fire I get it dude understand that
things past you know it'll get worse
also but it'll also get better like
things get really good but they also get
really bad I feel like a big thing is
like you just can't know everything I
feel like everybody wants to know the
answers to what's gonna happen and why
we're doing things you do and where we
go and like you just have to know that
you can't know know that you don't know
no you can't know know that it will be
okay and also it won't be okay but
eventually you will and you'll stay
breathing we're provided by the loving
Best Friends Animal Society and for more
information on how to adopt you in the
best friend go-to best friends that'll
work and you can get it out baby to keep
for yourself if you save a little life
because look at the little thingy
[Music]